foreign
let's talk about our breasts yup your
breasts are beautiful and unique to you
so today I want to have an open
conversation about our breath
specifically in relation to fitness
ladies if you have any questions or
concerns do let me know in the comment
section and let's talk about it one of
the most common questions I get asked is
how can I reduce or increase the size of
my breast here are 5 facts you should
know about your breasts now before we
get into it let's first understand the
anatomy of your breasts your breasts are
made out of fat and fibrous tissue as
well as glands and ducts that make
breast milk fatty tissue makes up the
bulk of the breasts hence your body fat
percentage will influence the size of
your breath
just like your body our breasts come in
all shapes and sizes your breast size is
hereditary some of us are blessed with
Fuller boobs whereas some are blessed
with smaller boobs whatever the size of
your boobs are they are equally just as
beautiful and you can't change it no
matter how much exercises or massaging
you do
this leads on to the next fact you can't
really increase the size of your bust
yep that means all the workout videos or
tips to increase your breast size isn't
entirely true of course there are
circumstances where your breasts do
fluctuate in size for instance during
pregnancy breastfeeding menopause taking
birth control pills hormonal changes or
whether you've gain or lose weight I'm
sure some of you might notice that your
breasts look fuller when you're on your
period That's because of the hormonal
changes in your body but it's not
permanent your breasts can grow as much
as a full cup size during your menstrual
cycle however in this after your period
your hormone level drops and your boobs
are back at its smallest yup thanks
hormones the fact remains that there is
no magic exercise massage or Diet to
turn an A cup to a double D cup of
course if you perform chest exercises
you will build your pectoral muscles
that sits behind your boobs which could
make your entire chest and breasts look
fuller and perkier in appearance but
that doesn't mean you can make a
dramatic change going from an A cup to a
double D the truth is for those with
smaller boobs the only way to enhance it
is to go under the knife or perhaps for
a safer option you can invest in a
seriously good push-up bra
foreign just as we mentioned right at
the beginning of this video your breast
is mainly made out of fatty tissue hence
losing weight or gaining weight can
change the size of your breasts if you
gain weight your boobs will be larger
and if you lose weight you might notice
your breath will shrink that's because
we cannot pick and choose and spot
reduce fat you can't expect to just lose
weight only from your tummy and hips
while remaining the fats around your
butt and also breasts I wish we could do
that but it just doesn't work this way
fat loss comes from all areas of your
body and that means your breasts as well
because they contain fatty tissue saying
that however this isn't the same for
every woman since some women have dense
breasts with less fatty tissue so again
it really comes down to your genetics
foreign
this leads on to the next fact what you
see on social media has been enhanced
big boobs super tiny waist big butts
it's not natural people with super lean
bodies who have a low body fat
percentage but with big boobs are all
enhanced through surgery low body fat
means you will also have smaller boobs
and the only way to achieve that bikini
body social media has led you to believe
it's unfortunately to go under the knife
so let's start setting a more realistic
expectation for ourselves if you want to
lean up you will also have to be ready
to sacrifice losing some size from your
breath what's most important is to
celebrate your weight loss and your
health with new smaller pants and bras
celebrate your body in all shapes and
sizes for keeping it active and healthy
so stop comparing yourself to what you
see on social media because it is not
real
and the final tip I would like to point
out is that ladies you should always
wear a sports bra when you exercise I've
even created a video on how to choose
the right sports bra and why it is so
important for you to wear a sports bra
when you work out so do watch it on my
YouTube channel when we exercise our
breaths move not only up and down but
also side to side and in and out
regardless of how small your breasts are
they will still move around without that
support the average a cup travels about
one and a half inches in each Direction
and a D cup bounces two to three inches
without proper support every bounce and
movement may result in breast pain soft
tissue damage and even cause your
breasts to droop over time as especially
when H is catching up so if you notice
that your breasts are starting to droop
from all the high impact workouts you
have been doing well it is time for you
to invest in a good pair of sports bra
to keep your breasts supported at all
times as our body and lifestyle changes
through age our breasts will also keep
changing they are the most intimate part
of a woman's body and can make you feel
confident in your day-to-day life so
remember to give your boobs the care
they need by wearing the right support
staying active and checking on them
regularly to avoid any health issues I
hope this video has taught you more
about your breasts so that you can start
to set a more realistic expectation for
yourself and most importantly is to stay
healthy and love your body for what it
is if you find this video to be useful
then do share it with your girlfriends
and do give this video a thumbs up okay
do hit the Subscribe button if you
haven't yet done it and do check out a
lot more workout videos male plants and
also fitness tips on my YouTube channel
and if you have any questions or
concerns do let me know in the comment
section below and I will see you in my
next video all the best